now this is a very interesting topic why
do people in the middle east have some
of the lowest rates of cancer if we
compare this to the entire world
let's do a deep dive now the other name
for the middle east is west asia now
what's conflicting about this
information is they have a very low
cancer rate but a very high consumption
of sugar rate
and i've done all the videos on this
where sugar feeds cancer so the question
is
how are they actually getting lower
rates of cancer despite consuming so
much sugar in fact the middle east
consume more sugar than pretty much any
other parts of the world now yes they
have a lot of diabetes and they have
obesity and they have other issues but
cancer is on the low side now if we take
the average of how many people get
cancer in the entire world it's 198
people out of every 100 000 people get
cancer now if we take a look at
individual parts of the middle east we
have saudi arabia
96 people get cancer out of a hundred
thousand
yemen 97 people out of a hundred
thousand oman
104 qatar 107. uae it's 107 and kuwait
is 116 people out of a hundred thousand
people get cancer so you can see if you
live in these countries you have a much
less risk of getting cancer
let's compare this with australia
468 people out of a hundred thousand get
cancer
they take
number one they get first place in
getting cancer number two ireland is 374
people out of a hundred thousand people
next one is hungary 368 people okay out
of a hundred thousand
and then united states 352 people out of
a hundred thousand people develop cancer
so what is so unique about the middle
east
well number one
fasting ramadan now ramadan is a
religious fast that extends over the
course of one month now that one month
is just one month of the entire year
what blows my mind is they're fasting
right after sunrise to sunset so they're
usually eating before that and eating
after that so ramadan is considered a
type of intermittent fasting only for
one month and produces a tremendous
decrease in rates of getting cancer
that's quite remarkable so why does
fasting help with preventing cancer well
it starves cancer do you realize there's
between 10 and 50 times more insulin
receptors in a cancer cell versus a
normal cell what does that mean that
means that
cancer cells have a very avid or greedy
hunger for
glucose because they have more receptors
to eat glucose okay so
this is how they diagnose cancer through
a pet scan a pet scan identifies areas
in the body that have a very high
metabolism of sugar so cancer loves
sugar and when you're fasting you're not
consuming sugar all right number two
autophagy fasting stimulates autophagy
which is a condition that helps to
recycle
old damaged proteins it helps to recycle
old damaged things like damaged
mitochondria
and if we look at what cancer really is
it's damage to your mitochondria when
the mitochondria is damaged the
mitochondria then adapts its metabolic
system to a different way of
dealing with energy it for immense
glucose when you fast
you kick in this autophagy and you're
recycling damaged mitochondria which is
going to decrease your risk for
cancer
the third thing about fasting is that
when you fast you generate
new immune cells you strengthen your
immune system
your immune system becomes stronger you
generate more killer t cells
which directly kill cancer cells and
viruses and you also stimulate more
helper t cells which indirectly
help reduce cancer
all right next point about fasting
it's one of the best things to get rid
of inflammation
cancer tends to spread
okay migrate into areas of inflammation
so fasting is one of the most potent
anti-inflammatories so it's going to
reduce the risk of cancer being spread
also when you fast you increase the
antioxidant networks of the body
so these things that actually protect
you against free radicals free radical
damage like in the mitochondria are
improved or enhanced when you fast so
that's going to decrease the risk of
getting cancer right off the bat fasting
is one of the oldest therapies even
hippocrates
mentioned fasting quite extensively and
he had an interesting quote but to eat
when sick is to feed the illness okay so
you when you're ill you don't want to
eat very frequently and he was
considered like the foundational father
of medicine
okay fasting is number one number two
would be the spices that people eat in
the middle east
turmeric okay
loaded with anti-cancer properties and
it's one of the best things to get rid
of inflammation
saffron has a certain phytonutrient
that's very very anti-cancer cardamom
anti-cancer properties nutmeg
caraway cinnamon and coriander all have
anti-tumor and anti-cancer properties
plus on top of that certain foods that
have additional anti-cancer properties
black seeds
olive oil
dill
sesame seeds and
dates now i don't recommend consuming
dates if you're trying to lose weight or
if you're doing the ketogenic diet but
there are certain phytonutrients
in dates that have anti-cancer
properties all right number three low
tobacco usage
for women in the middle east okay not
men okay that's probably increased but
women and if you actually add up the
women and the men the reduced weight of
women using tobacco is so low it makes
the whole average come way down i mean
take a look at this twenty percent of
the population smokes okay that's one
out of every
five people yet if we look at women in
the middle east in iraq it's three
percent okay not twenty percent
yemen it's nine percent okay compared to
20 percent worldwide and then we have
kuwait which is only three percent saudi
arabia
two percent
the uae
0.8 percent of the entire female
population in the uae
smokes that's a very very insignificant
compared to the worldwide average and
then we get oman
0.7
okay compared to 20 percent
insignificant amount of women in that
area of the world
now if we compare that to women in chile
it's 40
that's more than two times the world
average and then serbia is 41
so
smoking is definitely linked to cancer
you already know that in fact the risk
of getting cancer if you smoke
or chew tobacco is 22 times the risk
compared to people that do not smoke or
chew tobacco
25 of all cancers out there are caused
by either smoking or chewing tobacco
and the other thing you need to realize
is there are 5 000
different chemicals
in tobacco okay in cigarettes okay and
70 of them have a direct link
to
cancer and just as a side note vaping
also is linked to cancer of the colon of
the lung because of the nicotine and
other chemicals
and number four alcohol is prohibited in
most areas of the middle east
drinking alcohol increases the risk of
six different types of cancer if you
drink alcohol you're more at risk of
getting cancer of the liver and also of
the oral pharyngeal area which is the
area in the back of the throat and also
includes the back of the tongue and the
upper roof of the mouth
and it just so happens people in the
middle east have the lowest rate of
getting cancer in this area of the body
the areas of the world that have the
highest risk of getting this cancer
are western europe
northern europe and north america all
right now the question is they're doing
all these spices they're fasting they're
not smoking as much and they're not
drinking alcohol as much
then why aren't these numbers even lower
okay
well
it's probably because they consume more
sugar than any other area of the world
as well as more high fructose corn syrup
and cancer love sugar it could also be
linked to the obesity situation over 30
percent of the population is obese and
there's more risk of getting cancer if
you're obese also they have very very
low vitamin d levels in fact eighty
percent of the population is low in
vitamin d and vitamin d
is very very important in protecting
someone against cancer and reducing the
risk
and it just so happens when you consume
that much sugar you're going to also
deplete vitamin d and vitamin d is
essential in keeping your immune system
very very strong and then one last thing
is called polymorphism what is
polymorphism that is this condition
where the genetics or the genes are
altered in a way that there's kind of
like a
defect in the genes and there's a higher
ratio
of people with this genetic
defect in the vitamin d
receptor okay for vitamin d
so if your
receptor
is defective and you can't absorb
vitamin d as well
okay
for some reason
then you're going to be low in vitamin d
in which case if you do live in the
middle east what you should be doing is
taking more vitamin d on a regular basis
all right now that you know why the
middle east has lower rates of getting
cancer the next question is
how can you potentially lower this even
further
and i created a video
just in the topic check this out right
here
you